Cú phổ sẽ tập trung thảo lận và cho ý kiến về một và khách uảnh rộng,
quết và truy true nấu tư quan trọng. Cú phổ sẽ khách cơ trời chính sách đặt tru trò hành hội
thành phố Xin Minh và đa nắng, cơ trẻ đặc thủ cho đừng sốc tốc độ ca bắt năm,
trù trương đấu tư cả hàng không cú tế ra bên, đừng bộ cao tóc, bên thành thủy và điều trình
trù trương đấu tư cả hàng không cú tế lông thành. Cú phổ ý cho ý kiến về bộ xung nân xanh nhắn nước,
một bốn thông ảnh lại nước ngoài đời 2 năm 2020, cơ trẻ chính sách phát triển
lượng cú trà ra ra ra đoạn hàng nghi phung trong hàng sấu hàng nghi phung trong bà mười,
đều trình dạm dự tán chi sự người kinh tế của bộ xe dự, để khách phục hợp qua thình
tai về đừng bộ. Sự đôi hiết quế số 1 bệm mười của cú hội để thảo gửa
khó khăn với mắc cho các dự án đất dài tải thành phố Xin Minh đã nắng và khánh
hoa theo kết lộn thành chà kìm chà. Sự lý dự án nhảm mấy một dưới
tương năm, cú hội cú xe thảo lận tại hội trường về các công tắc bảo cao không
hát năm của ngành thứ pháp, gồm tóa nhân dân tối cao, viện kiểm sát nhân dân tối cao,
công tắc phòng trống tội phạc, khi hành án và phòng trống thằng dũng, thảo lận
kết quả giám sát về dài quyết kinh nghi của cử chi và kết quả thích công dân,
sự lý đơn thứ hiểu nại tụ cáo năm 2020, giãn lật sự đổi bụ xung một số
đều của lột thế giả trị ra tăng. Đáng chú ý trong tình làm việc cuối cùng,
cú hội sẽ biểu cuối thung qua hàng loạt lột và hị quyết, măng tính bản lệ,
bảo vụ hồng hết các lĩnh vực trọng yếu của đời sống kinh đế xa hội và có phòng anh nền.
Tạo hành lăng pháp lý vững chắc cho sự phát triển của đất nước,
nhóm lột liên quan đến thế tại chính dự kiến được thông qua như loạt quan lý thế
sự đổi. Loạt thế thu giảm nhân sự đổi. Loạt tiếp kiểm chống lăng phý,
loạt đầu tư sự đổi. Cũng bối các loạt sự đổi bề giả, phản lý nợ công, bảo hiểm tình bười,
kinh rang bảo hiểm, phế giả trị ra tăng và loạt phá sản sự đổi.
Hủy quyết của cũng hội về kơ chế chính xác phát triển nắng lượng cúp ra ra ra ra
hành những thúc trong hệ sáo hình như chá mặc bười. Nói lột liên xe dự
thông hại tất đại và giáo thông gồm, lột thông hại xe đổi.
Loạt xe dựng xe đổi. Loạt thông không giang giộng Việt Nam xe đổi.
Cũng bối loạt sự đổi bộ xung một số điều về quy hại tốt thị và nông thôn.
Điều chuyển quy hại tổng thế cúp ra, thảo gữa có khăn với mắc thị hành lột tất đại
và chủ trường đồng tư các dự án lớn như cả hành không phút tế ra bình.
Lần bộ có tốt với hành thuy và đều trình giảnh cả hành không phút tế lông hành.
Các lột trình đổi số, lột chỉ tệ nhé tạo, lột thông nghệ cao xe đổi.
Và các lột xe đổi bộ xung một số điều của lột trình giáo không vẻ và sự hiệu chí tuệ.
Sẽ có phần thực hiện hoa trên lột cúp ra về trình đổi số không vẻ cao,
chỉ tệ nhé tạo và trình giáo không vẻ. Nó một cùng cố ăn những cúp ra,
chực tự án tòn xong hội và đi mặt an nước nhé.
Lột an nước mặt, lột bảo vệ bị mặt nhé nước xe đổi.
Cùng với các lột xe đổi bộ xung đến quan đến con người cúp phòng an nước và đồng tư công nghiệp.
Và không chống mặt bị xe đổi cũng sẽ được thông qua trong tần tới.
Phan thiện hệ thống tự pháp ở trước quyền lực nhé nước,
trung vụ không chống thông giống.
Dự kiến các lột phạt động giám xác của con hội và hội đồng nhân dân xe đổi.
Lột ghên trước xe đổi, các lột xe đổi về thi hành án hình xe.
Thế không dân, dấu nạn, tổ cáo, phòng chống hâm giống và lột tỏ ăn chuyên biệt tại chúng ta tài chính cúp tế.
Công nghiệp về tổng kết phòng tác nhận kìa hàng ngồi trang mốt.
Cái nghiệp trang hệ sáo của các thử quan nhắn nước thức cao cũng sẽ được phục qua.
Các giữa an lột, khi quyết về giáo dục đào tạo như lột giáo dục nghiệp xe đổi.
Lột giáo dục đại học xe đổi.
Lột xe đổi bộ xung một số đều của lột giáo dục.
Các nghiệp của khu khu hội về một số cơ trẻ chính xe đặt thủ,
vừa trổi.
Đầu tư trường trình một tiêu cúp ra hiện tại hoá,
nân cao chất lượng giáo dục và đào tạo dài đoạn.
Hãy nhìn hủ trong lệ sáo hành những chiều mà làm.
Các nghiệp giải quyết các vấn đề các thiết về giành số phòng bệp bảo vệ mua trường,
khoảng sản và phát triển tình tệ sáo hội vùng ra tập thiêu số như.
Lột giành số, lột phòng bệp, cùng các vật sự đổi bộ xung trong lĩnh vực nông nghiệp mua trường,
để chất và khoảng sản.
Hủ quyết quan sọng về cơ trẻ chính xe đột phá cho cũng tắt trong sóc và nân cao sức khoảng nhân dân.
Và về trủ trường đầu tư trường trình một tiêu cúp ra vệ ý tế,
nông thường mới, giảm nghe bệnh bứng và phát triển vùng ra tập thiêu số rất rản.
Hãy nhìn hủ trong hệ sáo hành những khu trọng bà làm.
Các nghiệp giải quyết các thân đề khách hắn trên cho các chú tâm kinh tế lấn,
yêu cơ trẻ chính xe đặt thủ cho thủ đồ.
Và vệ xe đổi bộ xung các nghiệp quyết về cơ trẻ chính xe đặt thủ phát triển thành phố của chi Minh và thành phố đảnh.
Cùng với việc tháo gỡ khó khăn, bương mắc đối với giảm tổ đồng tại thành phố chi Minh,
đảnh và khánh hoa.
Dự kiến khi học thử người của vội khoảng mề lâm sẽ mấy mặt và chiều ngày 1 tháng 2,
kết thúc tắm tổng làm việc liên tục không gỳ giữa kỳ với bộ mi hành ngày tật chung cao đồ.